c'est le cauchemar des gymnastes perdre
le nord en plein vol on l'appelle le
syndrome des twisted ou la perte de
figure
[Musique]
les jeux olympiques représentent le rêve
ultime pour bien des athlètes il ne
manquerait leur chance d'y aller pour
rien au monde pourtant aux jeux de tokyo
la gymnaste américaine simone bâle s'est
retiré en plein milieu de l'épreuve
finale par équipe pourquoi
la gymnaste vedette devait effectuer un
à mannar c'est un sou qui comporte deux
vrilles et demie vers l'arrière mais
durant l'épreuve elle atterrit invente
compléter la figure visiblement
désorienté
pourtant simone base qui est une des
meilleures gymnastes de l'histoire
réussi ce saut avec succès depuis
qu'elle a 12 ans mais à tokyo elles n'y
parvenaient plus elle a expliqué plus
tard qu'elle souffrait des twists is un
phénomène bien connu est le cauchemar
des gymnastes en français on appelle ce
syndrome la perte de figure ça se
produit quand un athlète n'est plus
capable d'effectuer une figure qu'il a
pourtant réussi des milliers de fois
pour expliquer pourquoi une athlète se
retrouve à souffrir de ce syndrome il
faut d'abord comprendre comment notre
cerveau à prendre des nouvelles
séquences de mouvements
quand un gymnaste apprend une nouvelle
figure son cerveau doit traiter
énormément de nouvelles informations il
doit comprendre comment le corps doit se
positionner à chaque étape et activer
les bons muscles il doit aussi traiter
toutes les nouvelles informations
sensorielles que ça implique ces
informations proviennent de trois
endroits nos yeux notre réintègre qui
est responsable de l' équilibre et le
récepteur de proprioception ce sont des
neurones qui se retrouve à travers le
corps et qui nous indique pour notre
corps se trouve dans l'espace à force de
répéter la séquence le cerveau intègre
toutes ces informations aient fini par
créer un nouveau patron moteur à ce
moment l'exécution du mouvement devient
automatique l'athlète ne plus besoin d'y
penser
par contre il peut arriver dans des
situations stressantes comme des jeux
olympiques que l'athlète recommence à
décortiquer le mouvement dans sa tête le
cerveau bascule alors d'un mode
automatique un mode d'analysé du
mouvement qui est beaucoup plus lent et
c'est à ce moment que l'athlète peut se
retrouver désorienté et faire des
erreurs et en gymnastique quand ça se
produit en plein milieu de le saut et
bien et ça peut être terrifiant
la peur qu'ils ressentent alors
l'athlète empire le problème seule
paralyse chaque fois qu'il tente de
refaire le mouvement chez certains
athlètes le problème peut durer des mois
voire des années
les gymnastes qui souffrent de la perte
de figure doivent pas leur réapprendre
le mouvement dans des conditions
sécuritaires comme l'a fait simone burns
la psychothérapie peut aussi les aider à
surmonter la peur qu'ils ont ressentie
durant leur sort à thé
avec des efforts les athlètes pourront
petit à petit reprogrammer leur cerveau
est peut-être réaliser leur rêve
olympique
[Musique]